hello welcome to science breakthroughs
from science mission answered I show up
I am going to discuss couple of
breakthrough papers published in the
week of July 28 let's start first we
will discuss a paper published by Paolo
and colleagues in cell reports on the
identification of a mitochondrial switch
to control tumor metastasis why is this
paper so important role of aerobic
glycolysis in tumor metastasis is well
known authors identified a difference
which primarily affecting mitochondria
mitochondrial electron transport chain
overload and inhibition forms his fate
with superoxide formation in both the
cases authors also identified downstream
effectors of the switch let's look at
the data from wild-type population of
sih a human service carcinoma cells
authors isolated yep recess following
three rounds of in vitro selection as
shown here these f three cells are
enhanced invasive activity increased
migratory phenotype enhanced glucose
uptake and surprisingly no higher lactic
production they also had increased
mitochondrial oxygen consumption and
section eight accumulation when author
subjected moderately metastatic f tenses
to several rounds of in vivo selection
as shown here they found increased
metastatic activity increased
invasiveness and clone ogenyi city
however there was no difference in the
rate of glucose uptake and let it
release and mitochondrial oxygen
consumption but increased sex in eight
levels were seen indicating TCA cycle
warlord in the metastatic cells in vivo
authors generated p0 with damaged
mitochondria and P Zod to as represented
here with total destruction of
mitochondria damaged mitochondria that
is p 0 when treated with retinol
resulted in decreased oxygen consumption
altered metabolism increased migration
and
mission our total loss of mitochondrial
function that is in p 0 d two cells
resulted in decreased migration and
invasion indicating partial
mitochondrial function is required for
metastasis partial oxidative
phosphorylation inhibition with low dose
of written on targeting complex 13 nitro
propionate complex to inhibitor or a
specific SI RNA against complex for sub
minute increased migration and was
blocked by antioxidant and ashton
cysteine and obscene similar result was
also observed using mitochondrial
oxidative phosphorylation inhibitor yeah
my tempo father showed certs mad and
pyk2 pathway mediated mitochondrial ros
tumor metastasis in various in vitro
model systems and was blocked by
antioxidant and SAR in a force mad
metastasis in mice / tailwind injection
of Evan to mercer's treated with
reckonin was abolished by my toe tempo
and antioxidant my toe q similarly IP
injections of my toe tempo prevented
spontaneous metastases in m4b mice this
is clearly demonstrate scavenging of
mitochondrial ROAS prevents progression
of tema metastasis and this is an
important finding next let's look into
another paper published by thamas
trimarchi and colleagues in cell author
demonstrate a role for long non-coding
RNAs I'd be calling them link rnase in
acute leukemia why is this paper so
important role of long non-coding RNAs
that is linked RNA in leukemia is not
known authors demonstrate notch one
controls the expression of link rnase in
t-cell acute lymphoblastic leukemia that
is tr lune r1 a link RNA regulated by
nacho
in leukemia controls IGF 41 mrna
expression and it's signaling let us
look at the data comprehensive mapping
of link RNA in t-all showed average link
RNA expression was lower than protein
coding gene expression authors found
striking specificity in Lincoln
expression for T or and normal t cells
link are any promoters displayed higher
enrichment of transcription and much one
promoter signals in addition to protein
coding genes many link RNA genes were
differentially expressed upon gamma
secretase inhibitors reit meant that
North Star not one signaling
approximately fifty-five percent of link
rnase whose expression was not dependent
were directly occupied by notch1 authors
found lunar 11 of the linker and is
widely affected in leukemia they found
luna-1 down-regulated upon notch1
inhibition were expressed in primary TR
and expressed significantly higher in T
all samples that harbored notch mutation
and localized in the nucleus which is
characteristic of link rnase authors
develop in vivo xenograft as a in which
human t all cells expressing and shrna
targeting lunar 1 or renilla control
injected into sub lethally irradiated
human deficient mouse and their
immunofluorescence was measured in the
peripheral tumors authors observed
significant loss of representation of
cells in which do not one was depleted
which suggested that link RNA is
required for efficient tumor growth both
in vitro and in vivo ectopic expression
of igf-1r efficiently rescued the growth
of defects observed following lunar 1
depletion in T ourselves suggesting
igf-1r is indeed a key target of this
link RNA for the abrogation of luna-1
muse
two independent small hairpin are in a
star getting distinct regions of the
transcript led to repression of IGF r1
these results indicate lunar 1 regulates
TR proliferation by enhancing igf-1r
expression others observe the gene
expression and say to determine if link
are in the activates gene tethering
luna-1 to this reporter stimulate a
transcription of the reporter to a
similar degree as shown for activator
hot tip additionally ESO mediate a
depletion of lunar 1 significantly
reduce the stimulatory effect using chip
assays auto show that intronic igf1r
enhancer activates lunar 1 which then Co
occupies the element and further
recruits mediator in order to sustain
full activation of igf-1r promoter the
model is shown here this is a clearly
demonstrate a role for Lincoln in
leukemia thank you for watching science
breakthroughs from science me